So I'm setting here with the founding CTO of Udacity, Mike.
Mike, how did you come to the decision Udacity? Because Udacity is running their
courses own App Engine, in fact that's what this course is all
about. How did you come to the decision of, of using App Engine?
>> The very first website we built was built
for AI classes, a single course. And it was
built on a bunch of VPS servers, and we
had underestimated the interest that we were going to get.
Which was awesome, but we ended up with two
orders of magnitude more users than we expected. And
I was a relatively novice web developer. And so
we hit every single problem you can hit, in
terms of scaling up the infrastructure to meet the
demand. And so the entire 14 weeks of the course
we were just playing catch up the whole time.
Fixing problems, and adding more bandwidth, and adding more machines
and memory. And coming out of that, we were looking
at launching a bunch more courses and we were really
uncertain about how much traffic we'd be getting. We've seen
a lot of peaks. And so one of the engineers,
we're a very small team, but one of the engineers
had some experience using App Engine. And, it sounded like
a really great solution to the problem of uncertain amount
of load, and took all of that headache. Because we
were spending about half of our engineering hours doing sys
admin and dev ops work, just trying to keep stuff
running. And when you have a small team and you
want to focus on getting new features out. And you
want to focus on usually working on what your good
at, then it is wonderful to have a platform that cushions
you, for the spike and the loads. And pushes you in the right direction.
>> That's fascinating, that's exactly hat we're
trying to teach in this course. What would
be your key messages to the students of
this course, what would you tell them now?
>> So I think the advice I'd give to the
students is, it's important to remember there are trade-offs with any
framework or platform you use. And one of th things,
after using App Engine for a couple years, we found is.
It seemed like there was a lot more work, at times,
just to get started, to get something simple up and running.
But, what we found with time is that it pushes you
in the right direction. It pushes you to the best design
practices, for building a scalable applications. Maybe, if you're trying to
build something which will serve 200 people, you could do it.
Quite a bit faster if you are just running it on
a single machine. But the second you get up to 2,000, or
20,000, or 200,000 users, it's made you make
decisions, which will really put you in a
better place. And that is, that's it, I
think the most absolutely valuable thing that it provides.
>> That's great. Thank you so much, Mike for taking
this time. I'm sure that the student will find this valuable.
>> Thanks, and glad I could help. And I really hope that after taking this
course, students have a little bit of an
easier time than we did at the beginning.